voilà
rendus c'est incroyable
non c'est pas ça
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être
non non
non et qu'est-ce que ça peut bien n'être
bon c'est
incroyable un courriel
à bonjour mes chers amis vous contemplez
vous aussi le spectacle affligeant de ce
pauvre casimir à il me semble encore
plus fou que d'habitude casimir qu'est
ce que c'est que tu arrives tilmont
prendre casimir tu vas tu viens on
dirait que tu es devenu fou moi sûrement
pas pourquoi battu ainsi dans tous les
sens chez j ai perdu quelque chose mais
je ne me souviens plus quoi je crois
surtout que tu as perdu le nord quoi
qu'est ce que c'est jeudi le nord tu as
perdu le nord du mont-blanc - enfin je
te laisse j'ai une réception mondaine où
l'on m'attend voir que se dire aurevoir
reçu du snob
le nord
si c'est ça que j'ai perdu il faut
absolument que je le retrouve à voile à
françois il va m'aider françois salut
casino j'arrive trop soir oui qu'est ce
qui t'arrive il faut que tu m'aides j'ai
perdu le nord
tu as perdu le nord ouais le nord mais
qui t'a dit ce monsieur du snob tu sais
casimir quand on dit à quelqu'un qu'il à
perdre ils nous regardent ça signifie
que non mais je me fiche pas mal de ce
que ça signifie je veux retrouver le
nord et ne plus jamais le père aurait
coûte t'énerve pas je vais t'expliquer
comment tu pourras toujours retrouver le
nord des enfants
venez avec moi voir je vais retrouver le
nord enfin
heureusement voilà assez pauvre casimir
qui a perdu le nord est ce que vous
savez vous comment on peut toujours
retrouver le nord comme rémy
avec les étoiles très bien à bout avait
d'autres d'autres façons avec une
boussole oui et si on n'a pas moi seul
comme le dirait bien que les étoiles
mais deux jours comment fait-on le jour
il ya pas des toiles n'y a pas des
points avec le soleil très bien et
comment ces personnes rémy moi non plus
tu sens avec l'ombre c'est ça quand tu
fais là
c'est ça quand le soleil est au plus
haut tu peux prendre oui tu peux prendre
toi mais si tu prends un petit bâton tu
te plantes droit dans le sol et fait une
ombre et le nord eh bien c'est la
direction de londres cette famille est
alors la nuit ce sera compliqué que ça
avec les étoiles mais avec quelle étoile
surtout
avec l'étoile du berger l'étoile polaire
vous savez comment la trouver dans le
ciel des enfants on va demander à julie
julie oui tu nous a préparé la carte des
étoiles bien un tir parfait alors à
lorient lala serait facile avec une
carte quand même parce que moi j'ai rien
contre ça doit me baguette un cac a
repris j'espère
garder
voilà une partie des étoiles qu'on
trouve dans le ciel toute petite partie
il y en a beaucoup beaucoup
comment s'appelle cet ensemble des
toiles hissé
quasiment chez pas rien la grande ourse
c'est la grand la grande ourse c'est
facile à reconnaître elle ressemble un
peu à une casserole à bon ou un chariot
a tellement à nous alors à partir de la
grande ourse comment fait on pour
trouver l'étoile polaire
rémy
mukubu l'étoile polaire c'est celle qui
est la plus brillante oui mais tu sais
il y en a tellement tellement dans le
ciel gris souffrance c'est celle que la
plus grosse équipe oui oui c'est une
bonne réponse c'est
à partir de la grande ourse comme en
fait aux
chariots lui parlera du chariot ce côté
là ce qu'on fait ça rémy qu'est-ce que
du feu ou multiplie par 6 c'est une
multi vie par 5 c'est ça ah bon tu sais
5 face à distance nous que deux à trois
ou quatre la cdu trouve l'étoile polaire
oui mais dans les deux cas de jour comme
de nuit pour trouver le nord il peut y
avoir un gros inconvénient pour
retrouver l'étoile polaire quelles
équipes
de jour comme de nuit les nuages nuage
c'est ça qu'on ya des nuages est ce qu
il ya des nuages évidemment on ne voit
pas l'ombre du petit bateau et puis ça
cache aussi les étoiles
mais le marché chaque fois qu'il y aura
des nuages je ne retrouverai pas le nord
ils bâtissent et casimir ce que j'ai
fait j'ai faire cadeau d'une boussole
c'est vrai
mais là je remercie ont fait les belles
ça ça marche même avec les nuages ah
ouais comme ça tu perdras jamais merci
c'est gentil ça alors je suis vraiment
très contente je perdrai jamais le nord
je vais aller le dire à monsieur du
cinéma merci julie au revoir au revoir
que guérir
ils sont bien débrouillés et les enfants
dis donc fait julie tu n'as pas revu
casimir depuis qu'il est parti voir
monsieur de snob non j'espère qu'il
n'aura pas suivi les nuits de la
moustache jusqu'au point d'honneur
françois joly cet épouvantable nokia
tune encore
vous m'avez reconnu et que s'est il
passé casimir tu n'as pas de nouveau
perdu le nord non mais vous ne remarquez
rien
sinon
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on leur casimir
que s'est il passé encore je suis allé
voir monsieur du snob pour lui dire que
je ne perdrai plus jamais le nord est
cette fois il m'a dit que j'avais perdu
la tête
[Musique]
adams a lui jugé non casimir sois gentil
mais je suis en qui j'ai même obtenu
l'an dernier le premier prix le prix du
plus gentilles et casimir us a alors
fais moi plaisir ne m'appelle plus jeune
j'ai un prénom qui est très jolie que
j'aime beaucoup je ne veux pas qu'on le
change bon très bien sujet aux pardons
très bien julie excuse moi je ferai des
efforts tu sais quand je suis de très
bonne humeur à bien j'ai envie de
t'appeler juju en tout cas c'est gentil
d'essayer mais dis moi qu'est ce qui te
rend de bonne humeur aujourd'hui à et
bien c'est demain l'anniversaire de ma
tante ernestine et elle prépare pour
tous les casiers russe qui vais me
souhaiter un bon anniversaire au
délicieux gâteaux aux gloubiboulga si
formidable tu vas pouvoir te régaler
si je ne suis pas indiscret qu'est ce
que c'est que cette lettre ça c'est une
lettre pour la prévenir de mon arrivée
oui parce qu elle ne prépare que le
nombre de garde fous nécessaires aux aux
invités mais elle ne va jamais partir à
temps d'alain pourquoi mais parce que le
facteur est déjà passée aujourd'hui et
qu'elle ne partira demain ce sera trop
tard mais c'était pouvant le talent
qu'est ce que je vais faire alors écoute
pour une fois tu peux aller chez sa
tante ernestine sans lui avoir écrit je
suis sûr que si tu lui dis exactement ce
qui s'est passé elle te donnera quand
même un gros bout de gâteau je suis sûr
que ce n'est pas vrai pourquoi parce que
si ma tante perles estime est la
meilleure pâtissière des casimir us
c'est aussi celle qui a le plus mauvais
caractère mais si je ne vais pas écrit
pour lui souhaiter un bon anniversaire
elle pensera que je suis venu simplement
parce que j'ai senti l'odeur des bons
gâteaux vient me mettre à dos à nantes
of quasi vide
tu veux que je te fasse un gros
gloubiboulga pour te consoler plus un
rien ne remplace les les gâteaux de ma
tante ernestine je te comprends je ne me
vexe pas mais il faut que je te quitte
tu vas pas me laisser seul je suis
désolé mais je dois aller chercher une
caisse de bongo qui arrive au bateau et
j'ai juste le temps je ne sais même pas
si je ne suis pas déjà en retard
mademoiselle julie
pilod tournée à bicyclette non non non
ce n'est pas ma tournée non je viens
vous apporter un télégramme télégramme
de voilà six facteurs
cause pas de camion stop livraisons
retardées un jour stop ce n'est pas
grave j'espère un non pas du tout
grâce à votre bicyclette vous êtes
arrivé à temps j'allais partir pour le
pot et faire le voyage pour rien mais
j'en suis bien content mademoiselle
julie bon je continue ma tournée parce
que j'ai du travail vous savez
aujourd'hui 1 enfin chacun des secteurs
un quasi mickey ce que ça elle voilà de
quoi risque problème on écoute j'ai déjà
assez quand lui comme ça si en plus tu
me fait faire un problème alors n'écoute
la grâce à un télégramme tu vas pouvoir
aller tranquillement manger du gâteau
chez pas tenter un estime qu est-ce que
c'est un télégramme c'est ce que je
viens de donner à julie cette lettre a à
laquelle on ne comprend rien adams est
écrit en style télégraphique tu vas voir
c'est très simple quand on envoie un
télégramme il le faut écrire que les
mots importants par exemple je prends
celui là coup span camion veut dire à
cause de la panne du camion
stop est un mot à part qui remplace la
ponctuation c'est à dire les virgules
les points les points virgules par
exemple et livraisons retardées un jour
veut dire la livraison est retardée d'un
jour bon j'ai compris mais ça ne
comprends pas pourquoi grâce à un
télégramme je pourrai manger du gâteau
de match et ma tante ernestine mais
parce qu'elle ne recevra aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne sera pas surprise quand tu
arrives à mais tu m'as dit que le bateau
était déjà parti mais casimir les
télégrammes ne prennent pas le bateau tu
me donnes ton texte je le porte à la
poste là un de mes collègues le taps sur
une sorte de machine à écrire et
immédiatement de l'autre côté de la mer
alors grâce à un câble sous-marin ton
télégramme s'inscrit automatiquement sur
une autre machine et il ne reste plus
qu'à la porter atteinte ernestine voilà
bon mais alors il me faut écrire que
certains mots à brive o oui ça ça tu es
vraiment obligé de n'écrire que certains
mots un parce que on compte le nombre de
mots et on paie oui parce que plus on
n'écrit plus on paye ah ouais bon ben
alors j'ai compris je ne remettrai quand
les mots très important voilà donc tu as
mon crayon julie oui bien sûr tiens le
voilà tu en as
casimiro voilà une formule spéciale à
gué des formulateurs jeu l'emportent 1
d'accord bon alors
voilà déjà prêt à partir facto mais
mademoiselle julie les télégrammes c'est
sacré blatter monica n'ont jamais de
temps voire
secteur
une deux une deux une deux une deux une
deux une deux une deux une deux une deux
une deux casimir qu'est-ce que ça mais
tu vas être épuisées en oui mais ça ne
fait rien tout ça il faut que j'aie
vraiment très fin demain pour pouvoir
manger l'énorme gâteau de maths interne
et steen et j'espère au moins quel temps
aura préparé une très grosse comme ça
j'en suis certain alors une deux une
deux une deux une trigger est ce que
c'est un facteur g un télégramme pour
toi abou je crois que c'est la réponse
de ta tante est restée elle est gentille
de m'avoir répondu au fond si vite la
noce de ta visite a dû lui faire très
plaisir
alors pas de goinfres mon anniversaire
reste chez toi stoppe tout ernestine
mais julie une vous pas conseillé de
manger du gâteau chez elle en fait c'est
incroyable
avais tu écris dans son télégramme mais
je lui avais me viendrait manger gâteau
stock prépare grosse part se dire voilà
alors
enfin tu ne m'a même pas dit que tu
venais l'avoir pour son anniversaire
mais c'est de votre faute enfin comment
peux tu dire une chose pareille
je ne comprends pas moi moi je voulais
le mettre bon anniversaire mais vous
m'avez dit que dans un télégramme il ne
fallait même que les mots très important
[Musique]